hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my first Luke Cage episode video
I'll explain the Easter eggs from the
first couple of episodes how the
characters are tied together but we have
reached the wu-tang off' occasion of the
marvel universe so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the first
couple of episodes so the first episode
it's up like the actual first episode
dropped so much information ties it to
the Marvel Universe he had like the kids
selling the bootleg DVDs of footage of
the Avengers during the event that's the
same way they talked about it during
daredevil season one detective scarf
name drops Thor's hammer pop talks about
those fellas downtown he's talking about
the Avengers you know I'll say right
away you know just after the first
couple of episodes this is probably
gonna be my favorite Marvel Netflix
series after that first season of
daredevil daredevil season 2 was awesome
jessica jones creatively was amazing but
I feel like the construction of Luke
Cage the way music is used and we've
matically into the context of the show
it's just far superior to the other
Netflix series right now and like we say
music is important to the idea of Luke
Cage in the series each of the titles of
the episodes is the title of a Gangstar
song so when watching the Netflix Luke
Cage playlist it's almost like you're
listening to a Luke Cage album so think
of the series is being constructed the
way you would construct a hip-hop album
now obviously we still have Iron Fist we
still have the Punisher we still have
defenders and in the next seasons of all
these shows so I think that all the
shows will slowly get better as they all
start to experiment in their own
separate genres because like even though
they have all these things in these
Easter eggs tying themselves together
like you see a lot of Jessica Jones
daredevil stuff going on here they all
feel very different so it's gonna be
really fun to see how they weave all
these different types of characters
together during defenders next year but
you also probably notice the music it's
totally amazing
so cottonmouths nightclub is a big
location for the series you kind of jump
off there throughout the episode they
weave the performance into the action of
each of the episodes in the creator of
the show called this like the wu-tang
off' occasion of the Marvel Universe
it's just like Marvel's first big
hip-hop series but it might sound like
you might think that the
sounds kind of like a Quentin Tarantino
movie well that is because the RZA
produced the soundtrack for Quentin
Tarantino's Kill Bill which makes you
wonder like who man if this sounds so
awesome like that whoo tang episode 3
hallway fight sequence sounds like this
what is Iron Fist going to sound like oh
my god and they've already confirmed
pretty much they're doing Heroes for
Hire in season two one of the best
Easter eggs who is at the end of the
first couple of episodes where Luke Cage
saves the family that owns the Chinese
restaurant then says I'm not for hire
but I got you and then in the back of
your mind you're just whispering to
yourself oh he's not for hire not till
season 2 and you see he has all these
money problems well when he meets Danny
Rand he's gonna be super rich
he's like an Iron Man type character
just piles and piles of money so they'll
be able to go do their superhero things
they won't have to worry about money
like this but his big spider-man Uncle
Ben great power great responsibility
moment comes with pops death so that's
kind of his call to action when he puts
the earbuds in and the wu-tang track
starts and he just goes to town on all
of cottonmouths ashes I really like the
way they use the swear jar and it's
almost like that funny Captain America
joke to language ooh sorry that just
slipped out but you can see a lot of
familiar things in these first couple of
episodes I mean the hallway fight is
obviously the big action set piece
you're just like oh hell yeah just
destroy all those people and then
cottonmouths just lighting him up at the
end of the third episode now I've only
seen up to the third episode so they've
been doing flashbacks I think the actual
origin story flashback is in the fourth
episode so I'll talk a little bit more
about his actual like origin the powers
that failed Captain America Super
Soldier Serum project when I do my next
Luke Cage video but that's basically
what his powers are like he keeps
flashing back to prison
he sees shades somebody he ran afoul of
when he was in Sea Gate prison this is
all comic book stuff so most of these
characters are from the Luke Cage comics
so like when he mentions diamond bag
he's another Luke Cage character
comanche is another Luke Cage character
like he has that amazing sex scene with
misty Knight and she's like dude you
talk in your sleep what did I say
Comanche
Jayde's those are people that he ran
afoul of in sigue prison like he got
mixed up in really bad stuff tried to
leave it behind so that's why he flips
his [ __ ] when he first sees shades again
he's like oh dammit he's worried about
shades of recognizing him and telling
everybody so like he's trying to stay on
the DL that's the whole point of the
first couple of episodes he gets the
point where he just can't sit down
anymore he has to move forward always
moving forward pops so I definitely feel
a lot more connected to Luke Cage
emotionally and I think that has a lot
to do with the way that are using music
in the performances which are all just
amazing across the board I haven't seen
a single actors performance all the way
from the main characters down to like
the really small supporting characters
that I have not liked yet now there are
a lot of despicable people like
detectives scarf but they have such
amazing performances that it's like
watching Ramsay Bolton on Game of
Thrones like he's a terrible person you
definitely want him to die in some
spectacular way but it's so much fun to
watch him be bad in episodes so what
about the rest of the Marvel Universe
inside here they name-dropped kingpin
obviously he has the barbershop that
he's trying to say like after pop dies
they tried to save the barbershop I
haven't seen past the third episode so
it does seem like he will get the
barbershop back and I'm wondering you
know because iron fist in his trailer he
has that crazy beard I'm wondering if he
wanders in to Luke cages barber shop
asking for a haircut and that's how they
meet like ah dude where you been oh man
I got a story to tell and then BAM it
just like slams to black and you go to
the iron fist series next spring but
we'll see about that when we get here
and please be careful about posting
spoilers for future episodes in the
comments like obviously we know what
Luke cages origin story is so that's not
really a spoiler but like I'm expecting
iron fist stuff to happen if you have
actually marathon the entire series one
your champ but - please be careful about
posting spoilers about that before I
post those videos so feel free to talk
about anything from any of the episodes
but if you're talking about something
from like way down the road that we
haven't seen yet just please use a
spoiler tag so just to catch everybody
up on the character dynamics and like
how everybody is related to each other
so pop snap crackle pop used to be
called
pop because that's the sound that people
made when he popped them with his fist
so he kind of used to be a cottonmouth
type thug got arrested came back 10
years later cottonmouth was one of the
people on his crew she goes father was
the other dude who ended up dying in the
streets so he felt responsible for Chico
since he tried to turn good cottonmouth
obviously he continued to be bad but
still thought of pop is like a big
brother father-type figure so he cared
about pop that's why he was so pissed so
pop is also the father of luke cage's
dead wife the one that jessica jones
killed when she was under the influence
of the purple man
so that's reeva so when he's looking at
the picture and he's talking about
always moving forward I'm ready baby
he's looking at his dead wife's picture
that's how he's connected to pop he did
like they actually did this really cool
thing and I think it was the second
episode where they kind of make you
think like pop could be luke cage's
father now he's not literally luke
cage's father he's rivas father but he
became luke cage's father because they
had that conversation about dads and
then pop talks about his son how he
hasn't seen him since he was 13 I
probably wouldn't even recognize him if
he walked into my barber shop and asked
for a haircut
but that's just them messing with your
head a little bit just Ematic alee
they're so good with their
cinematography especially the way they
film all those misty night sequences
where she's working out crimes in her
head so the way they filmed the series
is just really cool in addition to the
series itself just being really cool but
the people are even more connected than
that so you know that black mariah is
cottonmouths cousin they're linked
because she is trying to do kingpin type
stuff clean up the community but she's
just crazy deluded about the methods
she's using to do it so cottonmouth is
the money that's funding all this and
she has this weird jeryn hogarth thing
going on where during jessica jones
jeryn hogarth is this attorney who isn't
really an evil character but kind of
becomes one through her actions during
the course of the series and she's
actually the attorney for iron fists
family so I matured to see how jeryn
hogarth gets weaved into this but black
Mariah
is the same type of character alfre
woodard character where it's like she's
so committed to helping her community
but just completely checks out on
morality just as absolutely brainwashed
herself into believing that none of the
terrible things that cottonmouth is
doing really matter all that matters is
her getting her name on the building
respect that's all she cares about
she does not care where the money comes
from but then cottonmouth who's also
trying to secure his legacy loses the
weapons and the Shipman in the first
episode so he needs another backer which
is where shades and Diamondback come in
so shades was somebody who was in prison
with Luke Cage like Luke Cage said that
he was framed for a crime that he didn't
commit that's how he ended up in Seagate
prison with all these people Diamondback
the person who is shades boss is the
person who framed him in the comics so
it's all connected like all these
characters even though it doesn't seem
that way are more connected than you
think
so a lot of the connections between the
characters they build when they do the
flashbacks so pay attention to the
flashbacks in the context they use them
in so let me know so far what is your
guys favorite moment about the series
what did you think about their daredevil
style hallway fight in Episode three it
was just like this whoo tang montage of
Luke Asian wrecking the [ __ ] out of
their crew it was so much fun and I love
that soundtrack it was so Tarantino it
makes you wonder what Iron Fist is gonna
be like so what's gonna happen is is
I'll post my next Luke Cage video in
another day or two so most of my episode
videos will post in this first week and
then once I finished with that I'll do
season 2 Heroes for Hire stuff I'll do
some iron fist there is a new iron fist
trailer that's going to drop at New York
Comic Con next week so of course I'll do
a video for that the timing is actually
working out really well because most
people will have seen all of Luke Cage
and will be ready for iron fist by the
time they do this iron fist New York
Comic Con stuff so get hype is gonna be
awesome and there is a new round of the
Marvel giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so what's gonna
happen next is there was a whole bunch
of DC stuff that dropped in the last day
or so that I'm still getting through so
I'm gonna do a Justice League
Deathstroke video next then I'll do
flash season 3 then
do another Luke Cage episode video so a
whole bunch of comic book stuff
happening this weekend try to get Luke
Cage in whenever you can but do let me
know if you guys actually make it
through the entire series in a single
sitting well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for the flash
superhero fight club trailer I posted
yesterday and you can click here for
that arrow trailer I just posted thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight